>>Peggy: Usually by starting with an
authentic problem in the community,
or in the neighborhood, you anchor
the unit with a driving question.
So students are given this question,
for example, "What's in our water?
And how did it get there?"
And then the students
choose different paths
to explore that question.
>>Sheela: Start to examine what's
happening in your local community.
What are some problems?
What are some needs?
Who are people that you can connect
with, that perhaps can offer insight
into a need or an opportunity?
Very often when you are able to bring
in a person or a group of people,
or a representative to a
community issue, a community need,
it becomes very real for kids.
>>Lisa: It's knowing people.
And knowing that the teachers
in your building know people.
So reaching out, sending out a
mass email, "Hey, does anybody know
in the community that works on this?"
And then just being very persistent.
Emailing, calling.
A lot of the experts
that we had only came
because I wouldn't
stop emailing them.
>>Sheela: We find that
the best way is
to take the kids out
into the community.
If that's not possible, then
make an invitation to who
from that organization can
come into your classroom?
If that's not feasible, we have done
really well with using technology
as a means of connecting with people
who may not be able to find a way
to come into the classroom, to the
school or for us to get to them.
So we found some powerful experiences
through Skype, through email,
through telephone conferences.
>>Peggy: Once you're aware of
this type of approach to teaching,
it's like you have
little antenna out.
And you start to look
around, and you see things
that could easily make
a good driving question.
You might see something
in the newspaper.
You might see something from a movie.
Or you hear a conversation,
and that is a great way
to start a problem in your classroom.
So usually these questions are
really all around us, it's just kind
of paying attention to the
things people are talking about.